it's disabled
it's time time Thomas my give me time
yeah
this is just the beginning hid her mouth
he's Brittany's neither I'm ready you
may hear but such to see
open your eye
you can become so much
[Music]
this is just the beginning
hey youtubers is Charlie so a whole
bunch of confusing dr. strange time Jem
looking stuff I basically like I fixed
some of the audio so I'm gonna replay it
again
only in the correct order so that it
doesn't sound like backwards speak so
here we go
rated pg-13 I'm ready this is just the
beginning open
can become so much it's time
this is just the beginning
you almost don't even need to know what
they're saying
you just look at the way he's
manipulating time or the way the
trailers manipulating time and you're
like oh very clearly time gem I have a
komodo so check that one off the list
I think we all kind of figured that was
the case if you missed the last big
trailer that they posted there was like
a bunch of watches at the beginning of
it like when he's dr. Steven strange
before he gets into his accident he just
has like a bunch of timepieces they keep
mentioning the word time the ancient one
says she was looking all across time to
find dr. strange so they've been doing
this for the last couple of months so
they've kind of been building towards
time gem stuff but I wouldn't expect
marble to actually confirm that any of
the trailers say they want to leave
something for the theater experience but
if you're a comic book person you're
like oh yeah definitely time gem if
you've been tracking all the Infinity
stones
you know the soul gem is like the last
big one so it's supposed to get a name
drop during thor ragnarok but that's
like a completely separate thing there's
still black panther there's still other
movies that the soul gem could show up
in but the time gem the multiverse
multiple dimensions they've been talking
about a lot of this stuff recently like
Doctor Strange is the introduction to
universes beyond the Marvel 6-1-6
universe which is like the main universe
in the Marvel comics so technically
because we haven't done multiverse yet
in the Marvel movies you could consider
that reality to be the 6-1-6 universe so
what I think they'll try to do when they
do more crossovers with other Studios
that have other IP like x-men Fox stuff
I think multiverse would be the really
easy way to accomplish that but the use
of the time gem just gives them some
really interesting opportunities with
the way they tell the doctor strange
story like if you've been watching the
flash this season they just did the
flashpoint paradox storyline where Barry
goes back in time changes the past but
irrevocably damages the future like just
completely changes it and even though he
walks it back with the help of the
reverse flash there's still things that
are very very different so there are
consequences to messing with time so
Doctor Strange not only the guardian of
this reality he is also kind of like the
guardian of time now that
he possesses the eye of agamotto now
that's really only the beginning so no
surprise that in the future you will
probably see the sanctum sanctorum at
Disneyland just a crazy Room of
Requirement style house that defies
three-dimensional space so we've seen
the cloak of levitation we've seen
different rooms inside the sanctum
sanctorum like the you know the big
sphere where they kind of monitor the
earth from a mystical perspective Wong
is kind of like the guardian of the
sanctum sanctorum so the eye of agamotto
time gem is really just like a small
part in the Indiana Jones warehouse
style Room of Requirement that the
sanctum sanctorum is is basically a
place where they keep a lot of magical
books a lot of magical artifacts that
are too dangerous to be kept anywhere
else so just like when you went to see
guardians of the galaxy and we saw the
collectors workshop like you had Howard
the Duck inside there yet Cosmo there
was even a Stanley inside one of those
cases just be on the lookout for stuff
like that inside the sanctum sanctorum
like really special magical artifacts
Odin's vault style it's actually closer
to Odin's vault than it is to the
collectors workshop just because Odin
collects a lot of powerful mystical
items that are too dangerous to be left
outside so it's gonna be crazy and based
on the pitch of the movie it sounds like
the time gem itself isn't even part of
the main plot it's just like a really
powerful item that pops up so it'll be
really cool seeing how Marvel deals with
the idea of time-travel the way they
perceive it because they're talking
about alternate realities so they're
just like a number of different
directions you can go with those kinds
of stories but just expect them to have
a lot of fun with it but let me know in
the comments where do you think the eye
of a komodo pops up in the movie is it
already inside the sanctum or is it
something that they find along the way
like something that everybody is trying
to search for in the comics the eye of a
komodo is just a little bit different it
just gives him the ability to see across
great distances dispel illusions but
it's based on agamotto the all-seeing
one of three very powerful mystical
beings so they're like three extra
dimensional beings that support the
sorcerer supreme at any given time like
whoever the sorcerer supreme is in his
defense of the earth in real
allottee so don't know if the movie
sidestepping them but it seems like the
time gem I of agamotto is being used
more like a time Turner Harry Potter
style just you know something for the
manipulation of time but in related news
in in like the TV Netflix universe I
know we have Luke Cage that just dropped
but they just did like this big
defenders video so I'm gonna post that
next they did like a funny defenders
Netflix and chill
so it's really cool they're getting
ready for New York Comic Con there's
probably gonna be a whole bunch of
Netflix stuff that'll drop I'm expecting
new Iron Fist footage but that might not
drop till this weekend so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
whole bunch of Marvel stuff dropping at
New York Comic Con this weekend along
with DC too so you know it's gonna be
awesome we have another infinity gem now
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for the flash trailer I
just posted a whole bunch of new rogues
mere master dr. alchemy everybody and
you can click here for my Iron Fist
teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight